many prominent people who had previously
pushed the vaccine are now regretting it
one example would be Nancy mace I
mentioned her yesterday Nancy mace is a
liberal Republican who came out she said
I regretching the vaccine I I feel I was
lied to I now have vaccine injuries that
I've got to deal with as a result of
this and I was impressed because Nancy
mace is a liberal Republican she's not a
Conservative Republican and she had
previously pushed the vaccine she had
peddled the vaccine on CNN
she was opposed to the mandates as far
as I can tell but she still encouraged
people to get it now she is regretting
it
that I said okay at least good on Nancy
mace for admitting she was wrong but she
still continues to double down on her
opposition to the conservative
Republicans she still spends most of her
time attacking the more controversial
people in her own party and she spends a
lot of her time sucking up to the
Liberals she did this yesterday at the
the national Press Club Nancy mace was
invited to go there and tell some jokes
it was supposed to be a roast kind of
funny telling jokes at the Press Club
here's the performance
I know George Santos hoped to deliver
tonight's keynote but organizers our
lovely beautiful organizers wanted
someone who could tell a joke but not
actually be one
come on George you've given Republicans
a bad name and that's Lauren bobert's
job
just kidding Lauren don't shoot
I mean really like who lies about being
about playing college volleyball like
who does that
if you're gonna lie at least make it
about something big
like you actually won the 2020
presidential election
I was one of the first Republicans I
know there's some New Yorkers in here
too Republicans who asked uh who said
Santos should resign
s should step down to show people you
can't lie cheat and steal to win an
election unless of course if you're
Donald Trump or Joe Biden
I said this so this can air on Fox News
and CNN
I go both ways I mean come on
you got it you got it
it's like watching a bad imitation of
Mean Girls
Republican Congress lady Nancy mace she
was she says hey
I'm not a regular Republican I'm a cool
Republican hey hey press
come on it's I'm not like those bad
Republicans oh cool I'm a cool mom yeah
okay right
are you are you that's never cool
unfortunately
even the making fun of George Santos
that's that's fine and it's funny I've
made plenty of jokes about George Santos
but it's it's sort of depends on the
spirit in which one makes the joke and
the type of person who makes the joke
in that
I can make fun of my brother you can't
make fun of my brother
if I make fun of my bro I don't even
have a brother I have a stepbrother if I
make fun of my stepbrother that's fine
that's okay but if you make fun of my
stepbrother that's offensive
so the question is what is the
perspective Nancy mace is coming from
Nancy mace is coming from the
perspective of a liberal Republican who
at every chance she gets attacks
conservative Republicans and and tries
to Curry favor with the Liberals
you could say well this was a roast
people are telling jokes that's fine get
a sense of humor yo I'm all for that I
think I think that's a great idea but
Nancy mace never once told any
self-effacing joke she never made a joke
about her own side
because her her side is not Republican
she opposes conservative Republicans her
side or the liberal squishy Republicans
and she didn't make any jokes about them
that's that's really pathetic
and I play that to remind you there are
still a number of those types out there
we think that the conservative party you
know the Republican party now is being
run by the conservatives not by the
squishes not by the moderates not but
there are still a lot of centrists out
there uh governor of New Hampshire Chris
sununu is floating the idea of a
presidential campaign I know it's very
silly most people have never even heard
of Chris sununu it's probably not going
to happen but he certainly wants to run
for president in 2024. and the way that
he is positioning himself is
specifically as a Centrist
a lot of the folks that you mentioned
and a lot of folks that we all know who
are likely to run for president on the
Republican side are more conservative
your house are moderate well president
I'm the most I'm ranked the most
fiscally conservative government of the
country I'm number one in personal
freedoms right I'm sorry Ron you're
number two
sorry Florida
um I would challenge anyone on Second
Amendment rights we're Far and Away the
best you know because we believe in
those individual freedoms uh regulatory
reform I'll challenge any state on it so
in my more social more moderate on the
social issues yeah maybe but that's not
what I got on this game for management
I'm a manager I'm a CEO I like to manage
and redesign systems but I would tell
you on those social issues we get better
results than almost anywhere else
there it is got to give the guy credit
for honesty he says I want to be a
manager Mike Bloomberg this was his
pitch to run for president in 2020 as a
Democrat he said look I'm a manager I
just want to manage things
that is
the exact opposite of what we need in
this country
I do not want to manage
the decline
I think our country is in Decline I
don't want to just manage the decline I
don't want my president my Republican
conservative president to manage the
decline
I want him to fix things
you might not think that well you
probably do think the country's in
Decline but some liberals out there they
might say no the country's not in
Decline even if it's not in Decline I
don't want you just to manage the
liberal establishment I want a
conservative to go in there and advocate
for good things and pursue good things
and oppose evil things
pursue truth and avoid falsehood pursue
Beauty and avoid ugliness that's what I
want he says look I'm very conservative
I mean maybe not on those cultural
issues
what is that even what I don't even know
what that means
it
it's like saying I love coffee I hate
caffeine
you're you're pretending that you
support a thing but then you you oppose
the essence of that thing
oh yeah I'm just not conservative on the
cultural issues
that well that's the whole story okay
you can cut taxes I'm very conservative
I can conserve
tax cuts maybe yeah I'm even questioning
whether that certain conservatives can
do that no no managers no managers no
squishes
there is too much at stake our
government is being run by people who
don't know the first thing about the
Constitution or a political order or the
law or anything and it's not just the
infamously ignorant people it's even the
ones with the fancy degrees from the
fancy law schools that the fancy think
tanks they don't know anything they're
so ignorant our genius experts whose job
it is to be genius expert nerds get the
most basic aspects of their jobs wrong
and make us all take experimental drugs
that often don't turn every well that
we're in a really tough spot
I do not want someone to just manage the
status quo the status quo is is very
sick and we need we need to fix it
Governor sununu you're not going to
you're not going to be the president
you're certainly not going to get my
vote if you want to manage this
desiccated degraded status quo
[Music]
foreign